Hey YouTubers, it's Charlie! This is going
to be my game of thrones episode 8 video so
so many awesome things and talk about now
that were in the last couple of episodes there
really like cranking up the WTF seriously
it took them weeks to film the last 20 minutes
of this episode let there be no more questions
as to where the budget was spent this year
everybody always wonders when ghost
doesn't show up a whole lot. They have to use CG for
stuff like that so bigger dragons this year
more white walkers. So just careful for spoilers from
the episode if you haven't seen it yet so
I'm the start with the the really big stuff
first just a quick reminder new round of
the giveaway starts now all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a comment on this video I'll announce the winner in my
Q&A tomorrow the person that we saw on the episode was the Night's King obviously looks
a little bit different than what he looked
like last year and is what he looked like
an episode for last year as you can see they
just did much better job on the effects just
because they want him to be like him a practical
person the could walk around and interact
with everyone else really only saw his face
last year I do believe that this is the original
Knights King the former Lord commander that
was turned and married the white walker bride
and then came back to rule over the nights
watch late like that is own small personal
Fyfe them even though that last big scene
of him raising up all those dead people and
turning them into whites was it was a big
deal any white walker can do that they all
have magic the Night's King just has more
powerful magic they just had him do it for
dramatic effect year just to show off some
swagger so smooth the top seven WTF just chronologically
to the episode starting with Tyrion advising
Daenerys to Bannister Jorah technically that
was in his advice he was advising her to not
kill Jorah so Daenerys to his banishment as
a mercy but is still really sad you do feel
for surge or others firstly that he knows
that his days are numbered because the grayscale
there really isn't like an unofficial timeline
is that how long it takes grayscale to take
over your body only that it happens really
quickly like within a matter of weeks probably
really didn't even look like it was that much
worse so I'm guessing he's only had the affliction
for a day or two I'm expecting the but the
by the finale like if he if he looks at it
again it will be way worse will be covering
like most of his forearm I'm not positive
but I think that this is also the first time
in Tyrion Jorah Daenerys seen in the throne
room where it said out loud the Jorah is in
love with Daenerys like openly in love she
probably already knew but I mean it's something
different when it said with both characters
looking at each other if you're little confused
as to why he took himself back to use on reset
you you let me fight in the big. I when I'm
yours he knows that he's going to die so it
doesn't matter I think he wants to have one
last chance to prove his love to Daenerys
visibly is like his right off in the sunset
you if I'm going to die I might as well do
something big make some big grand gesture
to the person I love on server Sixto Tyrion
explains to Daenerys why she can't just march
into westeros is all about the difference
between gaining the support of the people
versus the support of the nobles Tyrion explains
to her that you know she's freed all the slaves
in cyberspace so they love her but all the
nobles still Hayter should get that big problem
memory in right now remember Daario wanted
her to pour red wedding moment and kill all
the heads of the houses in the city Tyrion
resist reminding her that politics are much
bigger deal westeros she's going to need support
from the nobles he is valuable to her because
politics or what he does really well but it
was as if it was fun seeing them chat together
to terrible children of to terrible fathers
and if you didn't recognize it whenever she
was giving that speech you know I'm not going
to stop the wheel I'm going to break it that
was from the trailer you take that to mean
a lot of different things I feel like Daenerys
and in her own mind thinks that she's going
to march into westeros and get rid of a lot
of the inequalities between the really rich
people in the really poor people Tyrion actually
suggested to her that she stay in the East
maybe this is where you belong but as Daenerys
said this is not my home that that's basically
the show telling you that know she will not
stay put forever of actually they will make
their way to westeros but that is still a
long ways off I feel like this I can happen
for a while remember in order to get all those
people over to westeros these delete ships
which they do not have right now that seems
like a season six problem to solve any the
funniest part does when Tyrion said the only
person I trust more than Varys is my brother
and ears like you mean the one that killed
my father is like you get that someone living
up to number five Sansa finds out that her
brothers are not dead she seems like she is
getting stabbed here and stab your so I'm
I'm hoping at some point she just snaps and
does something retyped torture upon Ramsey
your veranda or even the on himself it would
definitely go a long ways towards addressing
some of the issues with Sansa this season
so far she's got a back full bed Ameche started
the really powerful place and we got on all
this Ramsey business in now it finally looks
like she's going to do something about it
if you just get the like that glimmer of hope
I was just like wait a minute my brothers
is still alive where they go everybody always
asked me about Rick and like where's Rick
and so in the context of the story he is just
with OSHA hiding off on an island both the
show and George R Martin just just don't need
them the story doesn't need him right now
so he'll probably come back at some point
or he could just live on that island for the
rest of his life and yes his dire Wolf shaggy
dog is still live to bran of course years
of training with the 3 Eyed Raven Way N. of
the wall he won't be back till season six
but he will be back because it is really important
character onto number four or he gets ready
to take her first mission taking on a new
identity in the process as predicted it it
doesn't look like she's going to be changing
her face but she does have a new Costa but
she has a new look this is actually on the
cover of entertainment weekly like before
the start of the season you can see the like
you know what she was talking to Jack and
she almost has a down: she makes a few slip-ups
but she's essentially she's got this persona
I love how the wave objected to Jack and any
just said well you know it's all the same
to the many phase God whether she lives or
dies that might seem kind of bleak but it
just shows you how stone called the faceless
men are they believe in justice that the arias
mission is all about but they're not really
about sentiment don't expect any hugs from
them I think my favorite thing about the arias
scene that was a way to edit it just just
the way you get to see Arya in this persona
wall REI third person was narrating it to
Jack and began to number three pretty much
everybody is telling Cersei to confessor crimes
before the trial this is a nice follow-up
to the moment where she she almost like hallucinated
Aryathe way the it made it seem
that way she wasn't actually hallucinating
Arya but it's a nice follow-up on Arya's prayer
because Cersei is definitely high on that
list we have Qyburn telling Cersei that in
no uncertain terms she will not get a fair
trial so the only way out is to confess it's
a little hard to tell you know which crimes
of Cersei is that they know about right now
Qyburn said that they know about the incest
in King Robert's death but those are all things
that Lancel told them I don't think Lancel
knows about all of Jamie and Cersei's children
so when they say incest just forget about
that briefly the only way that they would
find out about that is that Cersei were to
confess that really this is a battle between
Cersei and that none is it was, like they
are playing the game of faces like she just
getting whacked and whacked and whacked for
not confessing one of the best Cersei scenes
this week does what she got so desperate that
she was sucking water off the floor the black
cells the show doesn't do it justice like
these are literally like the dirtiest places
you could go to the side for maybe flee bottom
on summer three all he asks Sam well why John
has to help the Wildlings in every episode
since Jon announced his plan whatever all the
shows up he just keeps coming back to this
they killed my family why you doing this there
is definitely a reason for this because always
issue a really small character he's probably
going to doing something really crazy that
gets tied up in a big book plot that I
won't get into just avoid spoilers. Here's the thing
about were all his headspace is right now
and with Samwell told him your yet to think
about making hard choices things that seem
wrong now but in the long term right Samuel
was talking about John getting the Wildlings
that obviously you're very hard thing to do
right now the long term they need them to
fight the white walkers always though in like
a really nasty twist to that is probably thinking
the exact opposite thing is going to do something
to satisfy his need for revenge in the short
term that will wind up in the long term being
really really bad I don't make too many predictions
out Yunnan on what those long-term consequences
of what all he does could be what awaits a
lot to the finale go but that's something
really interesting that you guys should all
remember onto number two Jon Snow arrives
at Hardhome would torment giant Spain they
greeted of course by the Lord of bones which
we haven't seen in forever I think the last
time we saw him was when John first tried
to infiltrate Mance's camp way way back the
Lord of bones is like the Wildlings version
of all he is like I don't understand why we
have to do this is bull crap will do that
pretty crow you have there you know it's all
torment just beats the crap out of him with
his own weapon everything that happened in
that meeting with the elders is just to like
show us on screen the consequences of what
happens when you don't work together just
speaking in terms of numbers John said about
5000 people agreed to go with them not including
fans that is definitely against working with
the crows which are those really funny that
he that John King crow you could twist that
metaphoric to like it makes King reference
because he was a crow himself and he was commander
of the Knights watched just like John is that
they have about 5000 Wildlings in when you
look at the shoreline like you can see just
bodies for miles too bad it seems like 90%
of those people are now whites in the army
of the Night's King I know is that they were
running away it seems like they left the driving
class but remember Stannis said that Dragonstone
is full of Dragon class so like they make
and go get more if they need to the battle
itself was like that the hardest thing for
them to shoot the season intern terms of time
it took the longest I mean the episodes typically
take anywhere between like a in two weeks
to film this was like most like twice that
if I make my number one WTF the Night's King
takes a weird interest in Jon Snow notice
how long his gaze lingers on John Snow as
he shatters a regular white walker with his
blade with long call the reason they should
the white walker shattering regular weapons
with his eyes played is because they wanted
that big Valyrian Steel reaction whenever
Jon Snow's blade did not smash. very effective
and the explodey ice effect, way better than
when Samwell killed the white walker and it seems like
it hasn't been that long but visual effects
get a lot better every years the technology
gets that much more advanced so Jon Snow
versus white walker Jon wins big they get
away but they lose big time because all those
people are whites now is almost like he was
giving them the middle finger while he is
raising all those Wights up but it does seem
like good Night's King has taken a perverse
interest in John in the same way that Melisandre
is taken a perverse interest in them is like
he is stuck between the forces the right God
and the forces the great other part of me
feels like this is just the show putting the
question to you you know like which side will
he fall on will the Night's King turned Jon
into another Night's King or will Melisandre
do something else, like turn him into Azor Ahai
that feels like a question that
they're not going to answer this season it's just
way too big. They're gonna save that for
later in the big question for you guys do
you think the Night's King is taken an interest
in Jon what do you think he wants to do with
him those asking about Hardhome just because
they didn't get a bonus video on it it it
in the context of a song of ice and fire it's
like this Roanoke type settlement you whereby
the original inhabitants like you way way
long time ago just suddenly vanished it's
believed that they were captured by Slavers
but it has something up like this ghostly
power over it that people think that Hardhome
is haunted but the Wildlings are so desperate
that they don't care that's why they're hold
up there is literally like the only civilized
port on westeros north of the wall so that
the only place you can go where you can dock
ships his battle with the white walkers only
get to make this post stories that people
talk about Hardhome that much worse. As you
get the idea like it is like a cursed place
couple things we have to look forward to Kevin
Lannister is back in hates Cersei's guidance
he's taking control the small counsel he doesn't
care about her at all is is I get whatever
cares about her so we have the trial to look
forward to comic exiting like it to be a nice
perverse twist on Tyrions trial from last
season and Jamie hasn't responded to communications
although in the in the teaser for the next
episode we do see that he's going to be meeting
with Doran Martell to decide what his fate
is going to be either as the choice to stay
in door or go back to Kings Landing so I might
see him really interested to see which direction
the show goes with that it's one of the major
departures from the books in terms of storylines
is Jamie storyline but I feel like it has
potential song, and to be optimistic about
it because this episode dealt with so many
new concepts like the Night's King white walkers
the long night, add some links in the description
for videos that I've already done based on
some of that stuff so just check the description
so don't forget I'll be posting the Q&A for
this tomorrow and why he is with a that you
can click here to sort all about your great
joy this is a rumor that he might be cast
for season six and you can click here for
last week's episode thank you so much for
watching everybody. See you guys tonight!